Smarr: I'm Joseph Smarr.
I'm from Plaxo.
I'm really happy to be here.
This is my second Google I/O,
and no better way
to sort of benchmark
how much progress we've made
in the last year,
which is mainly what I want
to share with you guys.
Please feel free
to ask questions
throughout the session
if you have.
There's microphones.
But I think
if I time this right
there should be plenty
of time at the end
for Q and A too, so I really
hope if you have questions,
you'll get a chance to ask them.
And gonna try to do a lot
of demos here.
I know the WiFi Internet's
been a little bit flaky,
so demos in a live setting
are always
a little bit masochistic
to start with.
But hopefully that will all work
because I want you to see
how much of this stuff
is really real
and not just theoretical.
And this little link
down here, if you can see is--
there's a Google Moderator
apparently
that you can submit questions
live as well
during this presentation.
So ISGDHJQS.
That's as merciful
as I could make it
for transmission over the air.
So I thought I'd start
by just briefly talking
about what I said last year
to kind of contrast it
from where we are today.
So I gave a talk last year
at Google I/O
called "OpenSocial, OpenID,
and OAuth: Oh, My!"
And it was sort of starting
to say,
hey, there's this groundswell
of interesting open technologies
that are starting
to be developed that potentially
could let you do
a lot of very interesting things
with connecting up
different websites together
and not having
to start over from scratch
on every site that you go to.
And the real question,
I think, back then was:
Where is this all going?
Which of these technologies
are complementary
or competitive and who's gonna
actually use them?
And what are users gonna have
to learn?
What are technologists
gonna have to learn?
And the picture
I sort of floated
was that I said
I think what's gonna happen
is there's gonna become a set of
kind of service providers
in the middle that act
on behalf of the user
out to all the websites
across the web
that want to be social.
And there'll be sites
that want to act
as your identity provider
so, you know--
okay, I've already got
an account.
And I said there would be sites
that would want to act
as your social graph provider.
So I've already got an address
book or a friends list.
I don't want to have to recreate
that everywhere I go.
And that there would be sites
that would act
as content aggregators
that would be able
to let you see the activity
from you and your friends
all over the web,
and that these would create
kind of a symbiotic ecosystem
that made it a lot easier
for new sites
to come up and be social
and let users come and find
those sites.
And then in particular
this would enable kind of
a virtuous cycle where
if it's really easy for me
to go check out some new site
because I don't have to sign up
and put in a new password
and fill out a new profile
and upload a photo
and all that stuff,
and if it's really easy
to bring in
my existing social graph
and find out who I know
on that site--maybe
it's a niche site
that not everyone I know
is going to be interested in
but a few people are--
then I can start to have
an experience there right away,
and it lowers that barrier
to trying something new.
And if then when I do create
some activity there,
I make a review or I author
some content or what have you,
if that can flow back out
into my aggregator
and all my other friends
who aren't part of that site
can see it, they not only learn
about what I'm doing
but they learn about the site.
And if they can then
go and do it themselves,
you can see there's this
really nice, virtuous cycle,
at least in theory,
that should allow lots
of new websites to grow
and quickly flourish
by reducing a lot of friction
all around.
And then later that year,
it became clear that while each
of those individual pieces
was useful, there was something
really magical about putting
them all together.
And that the--
sort of being both the way
that I can go into the website
and bring my identity
and my contacts
and pull information back,
that there was sort of a whole
that was more than the sum
of its parts.
And that was also reflected
in the technology.
There were all these
independent projects
that were started
for very different reasons
but all sort of started
to come together
into what we sort of loosely
called the Open Stack.
And that a term that sort of
people seemed to latch on to.
'Cause it was like, yeah,
there's a bunch of stuff here
where it's not individual
companies just with platforms.
It's really a set
of technologies,
kind of like a set of protocols
like the web itself.
It was gonna allow
all this creativity to happen
in the social dimension.
And so it's interesting
to go back and say,
"Okay, that was last year.
What's happened since then?"
And I'm sure if you guys
if you guys
have been paying attention
at all,
you've seen there's just
a flurry.
Yahoo's whole YOS strategy
is completely based on this.
Windows Live is now
a sort of aggregator
and--take your information
around.
Google, Yahoo, Microsoft, AOL--
the list goes on,
all being OpenID providers
for all of their users.
And on and on.
And then Facebook, right?
Facebook Connect.
Very much this same model.
Not exactly the same technology
under the hood,
but exactly the same concepts.
MySpace, same thing.
MySpace ID--
like Facebook Connect,
but in fact all the Open Stack
under the hood.
And then most recently,
Facebook getting involved
in OpenID as well.
So even bringing the Open Stack
around to everybody.
So just a real flurry
of activity.
Google supporting portable
contacts recently too.
And of course FriendConnect
being this thing
that allows you
to take that information out
to any website and immediately
drop it in.
So the little guys actually
have an advantage
over the big guys
a lot of times.
And as that was all happening,
all of these trends
were just having great success.
So this is, you know,
JanRain tracks the number
of unique relying parties
of sites you can go using OpenID
and it just continues to go up
and up and up.
There's a Wiki that tries
to keep track
of all the different sites
that have OAuth enabled APIs,
so ways to access your private
data without having
to give away your password
in a standard way.
And as you can see
I can't even fit the list
on the screen anymore.
This is a snapshot of some
of the feeds
that you can share
into Plaxo Pulse,
sort of one of the first
web-wide aggregators.
And again, not only
has the number of places
that have feeds
really expanded,
but the number of really
mainstream sites.
You can get your Netflix
reviews.
You can get the stories
you think are interesting
on "The New York Times."
There's all this sort of stuff
that you can do
that is really interesting
to real mainstream users
as well as all the early
web 2.0 stuff
that pioneered this.
And OpenSocial, I mean,
what a radical concept.
OpenSocial only started publicly
a few months before last year's
Google I/O talk.
And not only did they get all
of these different big sites
as a community to come together
to say,
"Yes, let's have a standard
platform
"for building these social
applications.
Let's not have the browser wars
but worse."
It's now deployed
on enough sites
that, collectively speaking,
it's hitting
hundreds and hundreds
of millions of users.
So again,
very mainstream adoption
in a very short period of time
of these new technologies.
Just to me, that--
really extraordinary
to watch that
pace of innovation.
So when I take that
all together,
seems very clear to me,
and I hope it's clear to you,
that the whole web
is going social
and the social web
is going open.
And that's a pretty fundamental
transformation.
In fact, a lot of people,
I think,
feel that it's as fundamental
as the birth of the web itself--
where you had this sort
of new paradigm,
this new ecosystem
that was gonna foster
just an absolutely rapid
amount of innovation
because the protocols
themselves
were fundamentally open
to anybody with a good idea
to come in and play.
And so there's a lot of things
you can now do
to take advantage of that.
And so I want to show you
throughout most of this talk
is all the things you can
actually go do today
and that people are doing
to start to live
in this new social ecosystem.
Because even though this has
been happening so rapidly,
or maybe because it's been
happening so rapidly,
I think a lot of people
haven't really woken up
to just how much of the stuff
is actually real,
how much of it is actually
suitable for mainstream users,
and how powerful it can be
for your applications.
And so four things I want to
just sort of focus on
is areas that can add value
to your services right now.
One is how to streamline
your sign-up flow.
So how to make it easy
for new people to come
and find out your app
without having to create
yet another account, another
password, another profile,
photo, on and on and on.
Putting and end to what we call
refriend madness,
which is not having to refriend
the same person
everywhere you go.
So you can say, "Yes,
I've already made friends here.
Let me use that existing
friends list on this new site."
Getting rid of the password
anti-pattern,
which is where sites
ask you for your password
to another service in order
to access data
on your behalf, right?
That's obviously sort
of scary
from a security and privacy
perspective.
And scraping is also,
technically speaking,
kind of ugly and breaks a lot.
But until there were good
robust APIs and standards,
there often wasn't
an alternative for doing
real deep integrations.
And so now we're finally
getting to the point
where the safe and secure way
is actually better
than the insecure way.
And then finally,
what I call
"riding that virtuous cycle
of social discovery."
So being able to actually
have your app go through
that loop where more people
can discover it and share it
with their friends, and they can
come find it and so forth.
And so I thought rather
than just talking,
I would try to show you
as many demos of this
in the wild as I could,
and then sort of talk through
what's actually going on
under the hood so you'll get
a sense of sort
of what this really means
and hopefully be fodder
for some more detailed Q and A.
And I invite you to go
as high level
or low level technical
as you like.
This is what I do for a living
and I love it, so...
The first thing I thought
I would start with
is something--and most of these
I've demoed at one time
or another before.
There's nothing that
you'll probably hear or see
for the first time,
but if you're like most people,
it's hard enough to keep track
of all these things.
So hopefully everyone
will see something
sort of new
and interesting here.
The first one is an integration
that we did with Google
using a hybrid of the OpenID
and OAuth protocols
for an easy way for Google users
to sign up for Plaxo.
But it would work with anybody
that supported these standards.
So let me jump over
to my trusty web browser.
Okay, so here I am.
I'm Hong and my friend Joseph
has invited me to join Plaxo.
This is like
any initiation email
you get to any social service.
But what's interesting,
when I click on it
to go sign up--
well, gosh darn it.
It's already starting
to do this thing here.
Let me quickly go in and see
if I can regenerate this.
As I say, live demos are always
a little bit masochistic.
Hold a second.
I'll have to also see how flaky
the Internet is or not.
Let me try sending this guy
another invite.
All right.
I think probably I tested
this invite before.
Okay, so here's
a shiny new invite.
I've already signed out--yeah.
Okay, so like a normal invite,
but because the user came
from Gmail,
we were able to recognize
that, oh, you know,
there's a better way to sign up
with your Google account.
Sign up in just a few clicks.
And so we're able to give the
person a custom landing page.
And if the user wants to,
the can go through
our normal sign-up flow.
But if they click the sign-up
with my Google account button,
we actually take them over
to Google
and we say, "Hey,
we'd like some information
from you to get started."
And the cool thing
is we were able
to tell that they were
a Google user
because they got invited
to a gmail.com address.
And they're actually already
logged into Google
because they just came
from Gmail, right?
So it's a very smooth
experience.
And you can see it says, "Plaxo
is asking for some information
"about this user.
"They'd like your name
and email address,
"the language you speak,
and access
to your address book."
And with one click,
I can say "Okay, sounds good."
You're now taken back to Plaxo
and behind the scenes
we create an account for you
that's tied to your Google
account, so there's no need
for you to create
a Plaxo-specific password.
And as long as you're signed
in to Google,
you'll be able to stay
signed into Plaxo.
And so the first thing
I can do
when I get into the app,
rather than having
to get another sign-up form,
is I can just answer
that invitation.
So I can say--in Plaxo you can
connect to people separately
as family, friend,
and business,
and share different things
with those different people.
So in this case
I'm going to be his friend.
And then normally the next step
we would take you to
is well, let's import
your address book.
Do you use Google, Yahoo?
The standard thing you've seen
a zillion times.
But here, because again
we know that they're Google,
and they already gave us access
to their address book
on that previous step,
we can just immediately say,
"Okay, well, gee, let's go see
which of your Google friends
use Plaxo here."
And so we can pull
in their address book
and match it up against
the list of Plaxo users.
And again, the next thing
that they actually see
that they can do is--
here's a bunch of people
that you know that you
can start to connect with.
Right?
So just a very quick interface.
I'm not typing anything.
I'm just clicking through.
And I'm immediately doing
what I want to do
which is starting
to use the app.
So and this goes on through.
I guess the last thing
to sort of show you
that's sort of cool
about this,
the standard connect invite,
et cetera.
Connect to friends of friends,
And get some basic
extra information.
And when we land--the person
gets landed in the app,
we show them this little thing
that says,
hey, next time
you come back to Plaxo,
you can just click
sign in with a Google account
and you won't have to type
in a Plaxo password.
It'll just remember.
If you're not signed
into Google currently,
it'll make you sign in.
But if you are signed
into Google,
it'll just be magic.
And in fact,
if you come back to Plaxo
and you're already signed
into Gmail,
you just will be signed in.
You know, any site
will tell you that not only
is getting users to sign up
and get through
that whole sign-up process--
you get a lot of drop off
and a lot of friction there,
but lost passwords
are a huge problem
for any consumer service.
You haven't logged in
in a while
and you don't remember
what your password is.
Well, we get rid of all of that
because you're always
gonna be signed in
to Gmail
if you're a Gmail user.
So that's a good example.
And this is something
we went live with
just a couple of months ago.
And so under the hood, again,
so what's happening
is because it's been sent
to a Gmail.com address,
we realize, oh, okay,
that's a Google user.
That's likely to be someone
who could log in
with a Google OpenID.
And when we send them over,
one of the things you could do
when you're asking for somebody
to log in with OpenID--which,
again, if you're not familiar
with that basic concept,
it's like, I've already got
an account over on Google.
I just want to have Google
prove to Plaxo
that yes, this really
is that user.
And then it can trust
that--okay, well, in that case,
I'll make an account based
on that credential.
It's just in this case my
sort of Google URL as you will,
my own user URL.
But you can ask
for additional data
to come across
with that transaction.
So instead of just saying,
"Yes, this really is
Joseph at Gmail,"
it can also say, "By the way,
can you give me some basic
profile data?"
In this case, also,
"Hey, could you give me
an OAuth token
to access their address book?"
So OAuth by itself
is this nice protocol
where similarly you can sort
of bounce the person over
to a site and say, "Hey, could
you give this person access
to some of your data?"
But you don't have
to give away your password.
You don't have to give away
all the rights to your data.
You can just give away
a piece.
Like, maybe they can access
my address book
but not my calendar,
or they can read
to it but not write to it.
And so I can ask
for that OAuth token
as part of
the OpenID round trip.
That's the so-called
hybrid piece of it,
'cause it's sort of combining
them together into one step.
And so the nice thing
is that the user
then literally just has
to push that one button,
and all of a sudden
we get, you know,
the fact
that they're a Google user.
We get the verified email
address,
so no need to send them
that email
and say, "Hey, could you
click on this
and prove you really are?"
Because obviously Google's
the authority for Gmail.com,
so if they tell us
that's the right user,
we have to trust them.
And we get the address book
to be able
to start doing the import.
So really just
cutting friction down.
And like I said,
portable contacts
is the standard way
of using OAuth
to get access
to address book data,
which Google also supports.
And so what's neat about this
is we actually
didn't write a line of Google
specific code to do this.
It's just that Google
was first out
with all of this implementation
on their side.
So that's how it works.
Now you could ask
the question, of course--
so is this actually something
that moves the needle
on a consumer service?
Well, we're
a very empirical company,
like I'm sure most startups
these days have to be.
And so we see that
when given the choice
to sign up with your Google
account versus
signing up with
a regular account,
people choose that
predominantly.
And the completion rate
of saying,
"Yes, I'm gonna sign up
with a Google account,"
versus abandoning if you
just show the person
the normal sign-up form
is considerably lower.
So it starts out better
but then it really gets going.
So of the users we send off
to Google,
there's always this worry
that you're gonna send them off
to some other website
and they'll never come back.
Well, because you're already
signed into Google,
you've been conditioned
by the landing page
to understand you're gonna
go sign in to Google,
so you're not jarred by it.
It's a friendly page
that shows the little
Plaxo and Google logos
together.
It says what you're giving out.
Like, it's not scary.
It's very sensible.
So a whopping 92% of people
that we send off
click and come back.
That's an astoundingly
high figure.
Getting 92% of people
to follow anything
even on your site is hard,
right?
And so what that means
is that far from this becoming
the chasm of death where
you lose the person,
we actually get people
to come back in droves.
And then, of course, they import
much more successfully
because we don't have
to ask them for a password
or remember what service they
use or all that kind of stuff.
The contacts just come over.
And so, as a result,
because they've got more data
and they're less fatigued,
they end up doing
a lot more connection
and invitation
and filling out data
and all that good stuff
you want your users to do
than a comparable user who came
through the normal flow.
So it just moves all
of the metrics across.
And the cool thing is that they
even come back more often.
Because even though they have
to do this sign in
with your Google account,
which is a little bit different
than what they're used to,
they're just signed in most
of the time
'cause they're already
signed in to Google.
Or if they're not,
they definitely remember
their Google password
even if they don't remember
their Plaxo one normally.
So we actually get better
return visits as well.
And so the funny thing
is we originally did this
as an experiment
just to kind of test
how far we'd come along.
And once we saw how good
the results are,
the business guys at Plaxo
wouldn't let us shut
the experiment down.
'Cause they were like,
"No, no, no, no, no."
We're like, "Well, we want
to try some different things."
This is great, you know?
So it's actually now 100%
of people who get invited
to add Gmail.com addresses
now go through this flow.
And it's doing great things
for us,
and the users love it,
and Google uses it, right?
Loves it 'cause we're
not scraping them.
We're not being insecure.
And the Google user
now gets more value
out of having a good Google
account,
a good address book up to date.
So I hope that's a good kind
of concrete example
of how this interoperability
based on these open standards
can really be effective and
also be really user friendly
as opposed to some of the--
if you played with it maybe
a year ago,
a lot of it was still sort of
geeky and confusing.
But with this number
of mainstream companies
really working on it now,
the user experience
is something
that's very rapidly improving.
Okay, so that's...
Oh, and then the thing
I alluded to earlier
that's extra cool
is because this is all based
on open standards
and this was not a, like,
Plaxo/Google cabal,
anybody else who supports this,
it works.
So MySpace also supports
the hybrid OpenID
OAuth log-in and portable
contacts.
And so I literally took
this code
and pointed it at MySpace
once they told me it was ready
and it just worked
the first time.
That's pretty miraculous
when you think about it.
The idea that the marginal cost
of implementing with a new site
could be that small
means that we're much more
likely to work with
a lot more sites
and a lot smaller sites
because that barrier of
is the bang for the buck
of integrating specifically
with a big site
like MySpace or
a small, more niche site
completely changes
that equation.
And Plaxo's not the only one
doing this now.
So if you--FriendFeed
is another sort of real time
aggregation kind of service.
And if you go to their
homepage now,
you'll see that they have
these, you know,
sign up and find your friends
with one click.
Technically it's two clicks.
We call it two-click sign-up.
They call it one-click sign-up.
It's a marketing thing,
I guess.
With Facebook and in Google
and in Twitter.
So what's nice is that
other people
are playing both sides
of the roles, right?
MySpace and Google swap out
of Plaxo and FriendFeed
and FriendFeed
could do MySpace too.
So it's all--
works out of the box.
And then, I guess,
the one more thing there
is if you saw last week,
Facebook's now doing this too.
So Facebook started testing
OpenID support
on Facebook where,
among other things,
they work with this
Google flow.
So you can sign up
for a Facebook account
really easily and then
you'll stay logged
into Facebook if you're logged
into your Google account.
So really impressive
to see how mainstream
this is becoming.
And it's just unequivocally
good for everybody.
It's a classic case of just
removing inefficiency
from the system
and everybody wins.
And so I thought
to sort of pair with this,
I'd show you a MySpace
version of it too
so you can start
to see the pattern here.
And like I said,
if you have questions
as you come along or--
I know I talk a little bit fast.
I get kind of excited
about what I'm saying,
so please feel free
to jump in at any time.
Okay, so here's a little demo
site called 8-Bit Music.
And the idea is it's
a niche social site
for people who really like
the video game soundtracks.
You know, the little, like,
MIDI, "Do do do do."
That kind of stuff, right?
And so it's the kind of site
that won't appeal to everyone,
but there's a loyal subset
of people
that would think this
is really cool.
But it's exactly
the kind of site
where it's like, oh, man.
I got to sign up for yet
another account
and fill out yet another profile
and find all my friends.
It might be hard for a site
like that to thrive
in a world where everybody
had to do all that from scratch.
But instead they've got this
nice log in with MySpace button.
And so it just pops up again.
They do it with a pop up,
so not even taking you away
from the page,
a sort of very friendly thing.
And, you know, if I weren't
signed in to MySpace
it would ask me for
my log-in and password.
But it's a MySpace.com URL,
so 8-Bit Music never sees
my password.
And in this case
I'm already logged in,
so it's just as easy to say,
"Yes, this is me."
And you can see it's got
that same friendly UI
where it's got the 8-Bit Music
logo and the MySpace logo
so I can see what's going on.
And as soon as I continue,
then again they get--
It's hybrid OpenID and OAuth
and so boom, I'm in the site.
Here's my name, here's my photo,
here's all my information,
and I can start to find people
and share things.
So it's just really,
really easy to start doing this.
And that really increases
the chances
for small sites like this
to grow and thrive.
And that's
8bitmusic.jdavid.net
if you want to play
with that demo yourself.
I should mention
all of these slides--
I think Google I/O
is going to put them up,
but I'll also have them up
on my website
which is josephsmarr.com.
And so I'll put it up
when this talk is over
so you guys can
get a copy that way.
And I'm also jsmarr
on Twitter if you want
tweet out or follow
or whatever.
It should be easy
to get ahold of me.
Okay, so that was about--
how do you streamline
the sign-up process?
And that's very important.
But there's still the problem
of now do I want to--
I could import
my address book,
but am I still friending
each person again on each site?
And it's obviously the case
that you don't necessarily want
everyone you know
to follow you around
on every site you go to.
Like, I have different
spheres of my life.
Everybody else does too.
And it's partly
a privacy thing
but it's also partly just
a signal annoyance thing, right?
I don't want to bug all
of my colleagues
that I'd normally talk
about OpenID stuff with
with my personal hobbies
that they may not
be interested in.
And so you basically
would like to be able
to have a situation
where you can say--
in some cases, if it's
a friendly site,
maybe I want to say
well, gee,
if we're already friends
on Facebook,
why don't we just have that
be a transitive thing?
We can be friends here
as well
and in other cases be able
to just pick a subset.
And until recently that really
hasn't been possible.
But we did a pretty
substantial integration
with Facebook Connect recently
where I think we started to--
sort of
changed that a little bit.
So let's go back to--
let's see here.
Let's go back to that site.
Here I am, and I just joined
with this account
that I created from my Google
I'm importing.
So now let me go
into my Facebook.
And I'll say okay, well, maybe
I can connect with Facebook.
And I said let me not only see
which of my friends use it
but I can share content back
and forth between the two sites.
And so again,
nice little pop-up.
In this case you can see
it's not even a pop-up.
It's a little AJAX Lightbox,
because we've got some
Facebook JavaScript on my page
and they've got a little
hidden iFrame over
to their site so they can tell
I'm currently logged
in to Facebook.
And so there's no need
to actually pop up
a physical pop-up
with a separate domain
'cause they're not taking
any credentials.
So it can be an even more
streamlined experience.
It's interesting,
you know, the full page,
to the pop-up,
to the now the--in line.
And again, same thing, right?
I hope you're getting
a pattern here.
Plaxo and Facebook--
do you want
to share information,
yes or no?
So it's a pattern
I think the users
are gonna be able to learn
and apply
across different websites.
And so when I connect,
now Plaxo says,
"Okay, so now you tell me
how you want to use
your Plaxo and Facebook
accounts together,"
because some people
want it differently.
So the first one says,
"Automatically connect me
with my Facebook friends
who also use Plaxo."
So that's this case
that says,
hey, if we're already friends
on Plaxo--
sorry, if we're already
friends on Facebook
and we both have connected
our Facebook and Plaxo accounts,
don't make us reconnect.
Let's just, you know,
that's good enough.
We already said
we were friends.
And if you don't like that,
don't choose it.
But a lot of people
find that to be very convenient.
And then it says--
do you want to share things
back and forth between
the two sites?
And so when you go to do that,
because it's a deeper level
of integration,
Facebook says, "Well,
let me make sure
the user really wants this."
So they ask for a couple of
extra permissions.
And this is a nice sort
of model where
rather than having
to give the user
ten check boxes up front,
you sort of wait
for the user to interact
with the app and,
as necessary,
you can escalate the amount
of control that they have
so that it's really easy
to get started
but you don't end up
giving away the farm too early.
So this first says
make sure--
is it okay
if Plaxo knows who I am,
not just for now but ongoing
so they can sync things
in the background
and what have you?
Okay, sure.
And then the second one says,
is it okay
if you can take the things
you're sharing in Facebook
and also share that with
my friends over on Plaxo?
And you can see again, it's a
very nice visual representation.
This is actually,
this says,
"Getting ready to demo it
at Google I/O."
You can't see it but it's
the real data that I've had.
So it's very easy
for me to tell
what I'm getting myself into.
And so when I allow that,
then it goes, okay.
So the permission's been saved
and so, here, let me go
and set this all up together...
and wait for the Internet
which has been
pretty cooperative
but not the fastest.
Wait for it.
Yay!
So now my settings
have been saved.
And if I go back
to my homepage now...
Skip the opportunity to expand
my network since I just did.
You'll see that now I've
not only connected
my Facebook account but
you can see I'm now connected
to four more people.
So these were all people
who were my friends
over on Facebook and I'll
apologize for the names.
These are all sort
of test accounts.
But conceptually, these
are four of my Facebook friends
who I may not have realized
were even on Plaxo,
but because we all connected
our accounts like this
now we're friends
on Plaxo too.
And I didn't have to go
through the work
of bugging them each time.
"Hey, do you also want
to be friends on Plaxo?"
Because they all said,
"Yes, I'm cool with that."
And so again the result
is I start to get content here.
So here's a friend--
my friend Anita
shared some photos on Facebook,
and they're coming across
and I'm seeing them in Plaxo.
And here's a video that they
shared and I can play it.
If I want to watch it it takes
me right over to Facebook.
So it's a very nice, tight
interaction between the two.
Yeah?
The question is is the content
replicated in each site?
The raw content's not.
So you can see here
I'm actually over on Facebook.
So it's more like sort
of the feed
of the information comes across.
But we watch it every so often,
so if it changes
we can change it on our side
as well.
So if you decide
to make something private,
then it goes away
everywhere else.
But it allows you to see it
even where you're not there.
So that's another example
of how, again,
any website not only has
a hard time
getting users to start
signing up,
they have an even harder time
getting them build to build
that--a rich social graph.
And this makes it a lot easier.
And you may have seen,
since this went live,
it also went--
Digg did a somewhat similar
integration
where you sort of automatically
follow all of your--
the subset of your Facebook
users who are also Digg users.
And so that to me
was a really cool example
because I always used
to tell people, you know,
isn't it weird that here I am
in the middle of Silicon Valley,
and everyone I know uses Digg
but I have, like,
three friends on Digg,
and so I don't see what any
of those people are Digging
because it's just too much work
to, like, go through and build
yet another curated friends list
just on Digg, right?
But if it can happen
automatically
through a site like Facebook
that I've already gone
and built up a set of--
social graph,
now it's actually
a much richer experience
when I go to Digg.
It's not just kind of
what random 13-year-olds
across the world thought
was a cool story.
It's what the people I actually
know and care about
thought was a cool story,
which is a much more
interesting, filtered view.
And so that whole being able
to lower the friction
of getting that data to move
all of a sudden means
that you can get
a lot more engaging
experiences
and get your users
into a much happier state
without having to make them
do so much work.
So that's really
the payoff here.
And so again,
on the backend,
this really wasn't
too hard to do.
So essentially what
we have to do is
when somebody connects
their Facebook account
and Plaxo account, we just have
a little database table
that stores a mapping
between their Facebook ID
and their Plaxo ID.
And then we store the little
session key they give us,
which is kind
of like an OAuth token
that allows us to make API calls
on the person's behalf.
And then we can pull down
their friends list,
which is essentially just
a list of other Facebook IDs.
And we can intersect that
with our mapping table
and see which of the subset
of your Facebook friends
have also connected their
accounts, and that's the set
of Plaxo users that
we can auto connect you to.
And we just check
the preference
to see if both sides said
"Yes, auto connect me."
And if so, we do.
And we also--
I didn't show you this,
but you get a little
notification in Plaxo,
like, if somebody comments on
one of your photos or whatever
about each person
that you've connected with.
So if you decide,
oh, gee, I'm friends
with that person on Facebook
but I'm not really sure I want
to be their friend on Plaxo,
you can just go in right there
and change it
to business
instead of friend
or get rid of it or whatever.
You're never surprised
by what's happening.
It's very seamless.
And for most people
most of the time
they're pretty cool with keeping
the friends list the same.
But it allows you to kind
of curate it on the fly.
And then what we do
is we basically have
a demon that runs
in the background every--
whatever it is, few hours,
that checks, you know,
hey, do you have any new friends
on Facebook?
Well, let's see if
they're Plaxo members.
Or have you unfriended anybody
on Facebook?
Have some of your friends
since connected
their Plaxo and Facebook
accounts?
And so it just runs
in the background
and does that algorithm
over and over again.
And so the cool thing is
as more and more people
hook up their accounts
I just get friended to them.
And as more and more people
join Facebook
I get connected to them.
And so the benefit to me
as a user
and also the benefit
to Plaxo is not just
a one time thing like
when you do a one time import.
It actually keeps getting better
over time.
And so you get
a marginal return
for that one time
investment.
And so that's a really powerful
model because
especially if you think
about new sites that are small,
you may come as an early adopter
and try to use it
and not find a lot
of your friends there.
But over time a bunch more
people are gonna join
and you'd really like that
to be able
to bring you back to the site
and give you more reasons
to keep interacting
with it and so now you can.
And then Facebook has
this open stream API
which is another use of Facebook
using open standards.
They've really gotten
on the bandwagon
which is so awesome.
So there's another building
block which wasn't even
in that Open Stack diagram
from last year
called activity streams
which is a sort of
a standard way of doing
rich metadata
around shared a video or posted
a photo or what have you.
And so we can--
it's a protected feed
but we got
the access from the user,
that second permission
dialogue you saw,
so we can suck that out
and then share it privately
with the user's Plaxo friends.
And I think
what's crucial there
is that--notice that I didn't
have to make the data public
just to make it portable,
right?
So I'm specifically
wanting to share
nonpublic things with
my friends and family.
It's just that some of them
are on Facebook and some
of them are on Plaxo.
And I don't really want
to have to make
all of my Facebook friends
join Plaxo
or all of my Plaxo friends
join Facebook.
I just want to be able
to put stuff up
and share it to friends
in both places.
I just don't want
to have to make it public
to share it with everybody.
And with this sort of secure
data portability
you really can do that.
And so that's a really
powerful thing
that, you know, a lot of
the success of early web 2.0
came from just getting around
all these
tricky identity and privacy
problems
by making everything public.
But that's not really
what most people want
when you think about it.
And so now you don't have
to do that.
Okay, and then presumably
you've been seeing this
all along.
But you never saw me
type a password in once, right?
And that's really cool
especially when
you're using a tablet PC
because handwriting recognition
for passwords is pretty bad.
It doesn't really look
like an English word.
And so I wanted to show you
an example on FriendFeed's site.
I think they've done
a particularly good job.
They've got, uh, this--
you know,
Like all these sites, they have
a little friend finder.
But rather than asking
for passwords everywhere,
they've got this nice
streamlined interface
where it just takes you over
to the other site
and then shows you the people
you might want to connect with.
So you can see here they've got
Facebook, Twitter,
Gmail, Yahoo, and Hotmail.
And some of these are using
open standards
and some of them aren't,
but to the user it all
kind of works the same.
And hopefully over time
as more and more people support
these open standards
it'll be less and less work
for sites like FriendFeed
to support
and they'll be able to support
more and more additional sites.
But conceptually if I go
to--let's do Yahoo this time.
So Yahoo makes me log in
each time
because they're a little bit
more paranoid.
Probably for a good reason.
And then they show me a bit
of a scarier page,
but it's the same thing.
It's like, hey, is it okay
if FriendFeed has access
to your information?
But then once I bounce back
it's the same thing.
It's OAuth and boom.
You can see how fast it is.
Here's a bunch
of my Yahoo contacts
that I might want to follow
on FriendFeed.
Now if instead I decide
let's use Gmail,
it's the same thing, right?
So it's just very seamless.
It's actually a lot nicer
than having to type passwords
in because I happen
to already be logged
into those other sites.
If you're taking passwords,
you don't get the value
of the person
already being logged in
whereas here you do.
And they do Facebook as well.
And even Facebook has
their own kind of--
It's not OAuth.
It's their own version.
But it's conceptually
very similar, right?
Yeah, yeah, so the fact
that those other sites
aren't asking me for passwords
is because I happen to already
be logged into them,
and if I weren't logged in
I would have to log in.
But at least I'm giving
my password only
to the sites
that have my data
and I'm never giving a password
to FriendFeed in either case.
Right?
Does that make sense?
So that's a lot more secure
for me
because if I don't trust
FriendFeed
then I can always say
they can't have access later.
And I don't have to go change
my password,
and FriendFeed can't
go and do anything
other than read
my address book.
They can't go in and delete
my account or whatever
which any site you give
your password to
theoretically could.
So you really
have to trust them.
So this is a cool example.
I just wanted you to see also
that it's not just Plaxo.
We've obviously been
very eager early adopters
and evangelists of a lot
of these open standards
because our service
is all about helping you
stay in touch
with people across
all the different services
you use.
But lots and lots
of other sites are starting
to use these technologies
and having great success
with them.
And I think FriendFeed's
implementation here
is fantastic.
And so behind the scenes
one of the things
that's helping a lot here
is that even though
a lot of these sites
standardized on OAuth
for being able
to give access to data
without your password,
they still all have
their own contacts API.
So Google had Gdata contacts
and Yahoo had the Yahoo
address book API
and Microsoft has Windows Live
contacts and whatever.
And so even though
you could just use
the code once to get
access to the data,
you still had to write
separate site-specific code.
And really to have the kind
of virtuous cycle
we're talking about,
you really want
to have the protocols themselves
be open standards
so that you can talk to someone
you've never heard of before.
So if you're a small site,
you don't want to have
to convince FriendFeed
to add an importer
for your site.
You just want the user
to be able to say,
"Hey, I'm on this small site
but we speak the same standard
so it just works."
And so portable contacts
is a standard that does that.
And it's basically just
a very simple RESTful API.
You can learn more
at portablecontacts.net.
And it exposes--it's basically
vCard data but exposed
in a more modern way
as are JSON or XML.
So then it's very easy to go
and get access to that data
and it's
in the standard format.
And what's cool is
in addition
to just traditional webmail
address book providers,
we got together with
the OpenSocial community
and we standardized
so that OpenSocial,
which has a much richer set
of requirements around
building social applications
into websites
and so forth,
but they have a bunch
of externally facing APIs,
one of which
is get my profile data
or get my friends' data,
which is very much the same.
And so we were able
to work together
and wire align
portable contacts
and the OpenSocial piece
about getting people.
So any OpenSocial provider
out of the box
is also a portable contacts
provider.
So if you wanted to do import
from MySpace or Hi5
or Friendster or Orkut
or any of these sites
that support OpenSocial,
you can do it the same way
as you can
from your Gmail contacts.
So that's very cool to see
that convergence happening.
And it's all because
we got together and said, hey,
we believe that we can grow
the pie substantially
for everyone
if we can stop bickering over
the little details of how you
describe a phone number
and focus on building value
higher up in the stack,
and that's what allowed this
to move.
And a cool thing,
this guy Sean Sullivan
who just found out
about portable contacts
out in the community and--
whipped up an Android app.
And now you guys all have
your own Android phones,
maybe you can do this too.
It's called jpoco.
And again--
so you could import from
any portable contacts provider
into your Android phone.
So here he's doing it
with Plaxo.
And all of a sudden, boom,
you've got all
my information there, right?
So it's neat
how people come up--
We didn't even really anticipate
this use case
when we thought about
portable contacts,
but because it's a standard,
it's so easy for people
to go off and build the stuff
and anybody can go use it.
And so the last thing
I wanted to say
is so now
you're into the site.
Now you've got
your friends list.
But what you really want
to complete that virtuous cycle
is when you're making activity
or sharing things
on that site,
you want it to flow back out
into your aggregator of choice,
whether that's Plaxo or
FriendFeed
or Facebook or Twitter
or Windows Live
or Yahoo Updates.
I mean, pretty much all the
major players have these now.
And so you'd like the user
to be able to say
just like, well, wherever
you keep your contacts
bring them in.
Wherever you aggregate
your activity,
send it back out because
that's how
other people are gonna find out
what's going on
and come find out
about your site.
And so I think one
of the coolest implementations
here is something that Google
made called FriendConnect.
And FriendConnect does
a lot of cool things
but what it does is
it lets any website
add social functionality
buy just copying and pasting
a few lines of JavaScript.
So sort of like how in AdWords
you can just easily put ads
on your site,
with FriendConnect
you can easily put
social information on your site.
And Google hosts all the data
so that you don't have
to do any back end programming.
You just have to--
Let me make sure I'm still
signed in properly
and everything.
So this is a little site
called My Latest Piece.
This is like a local artist
that wants to show off
his stuff.
And a typical example
of where traditionally
you'd have just kind of
a standard website
that doesn't really have
its own programmers
or ability to build a bunch
of social information
and all that kind of stuff.
But with FriendConnect
they just drop in
this widget,
and so I've signed in here.
And let's see.
Maybe I'll show you
the interface.
Let me sign out.
And you can see these
are little iFrames,
and so it's just easy for me
to say, "Join this site."
And then under the hood,
Google's powering this pop-up
so they get this OpenID
sign-in experience.
So I'll use my Google account,
so again,
I don't have to create
a separate account on--
Let me do a different user.
On "My Latest Piece,"
I can use my Google account.
And then I can also go--
Now I'm in the site
and I can see which
of my friends are on
this site.
So that same cool experience
I showed you
but with even less work
than it would've taken
to build it yourself.
And if I go and look
at my settings,
what's really cool is not only
can I get into the site,
I can then hook up the other
tools and services that I use.
So I can pull in Twitter,
I can pull in LinkedIn,
I can pull in Plaxo and have
that information on the site.
And again, Google's done
all the hard work
behind the scenes
and so the site can just
sort of take advantage
of having richer profile data
and more connections.
But crucially down here
what you can see
is this option:
Publish my activities
to the sites I've joined
and add to my networks.
So what that means is if
I share activity on this site,
it'll go back into
my Plaxo stream.
So for example, if I say--
Going down here and say...
"Great piece!
Hi from Google I/O."
And now you'll know I couldn't
have faked it
because I wouldn't have known
that I was gonna be
giving a talk here
is the theory,
right?
All right.
You win some, you lose some.
[laughs]
O. There we go.
Okay, and then I'll post
that rating.
And so then my rating
will show up down here.
Then my rating will show up
down here.
Hmm, let me refresh that.
If we were using Wave
you would've seen it, like,
character by character.
Oh, yeah, so, "Hi, great piece
from Google I/O."
So that's cool.
So people on that site
can see that it's me
and they can see
my real photo.
But then what's really cool
is I can go back to Plaxo
and let me sign back in
as my account
that I was using.
And there it is.
Joseph posted
on a FriendConnect site.
Joseph wrote a review.
"Hi, from Google I/O."
And it's on My Latest Piece.
And so I've written my friends
and they'll see this.
They may never have heard
of My Latest Piece, right?
But they can not only see
that I did this thing.
They can just click through
and see it over there.
And then they can come in
and join their account.
And so that's that virtuous
cycle that I was talking about.
And the thing to me
that's so cool about this
is not only does it allow me
to use lots of different
websites and share activity,
but Plaxo's never heard
of My Latest Piece, right?
It's not like we wrote
a special plug-in
to interface with
mylatestpiece.com.
We'd never heard of them.
But because it's using
open standards it just works.
And it's using the OpenSocial
RESTful APIs with OAuth,
all this same stuff
you keep hearing about.
And that's what makes it work.
And what's even cooler then
is that because it's all
open standards,
Google can go make a service
like FriendConnect
where anybody could implement
this themselves,
or you can outsource it
to somebody like Google
and it all just sort of works.
That's only possible in a world
where you have these
open standards.
And this is really
fertile ground.
Most people are still
not taking advantage
of this stuff and it is
just gonna be killer
for all of your sites.
You're gonna wonder,
I think, within a year
how people possibly thought
that it was reasonable
to put out a new startup.
And it's like, all right,
now we just have
to get 10 million people
to sign up
and upload photos and connect
to 100 friends
and share a bunch of activity
and come back to the site daily
and we'll be set.
Like, that's such a high bar
when you think about it.
It's just so hard to do that
on a bunch of different sites.
And now you don't have to.
And so I think
that the real benefit
will be
all the smaller developers
who can just build these sites
that can kind of grow
and thrive
much the way you can link
to lots of different websites.
And a small website
can be linked to
just as easily
as a big one.
Andthen it can start
to rise in relevance,
except now the data's
moving with it as well.
And so I mentioned Facebook
a few times.
A year ago I think
there was a big question mark.
In fact, when I gave
that talk where I mentioned--
I didn't show you
the full slide.
There was the Open Stack piece
and then we sort of said
well, Facebook,
they're really not doing
any of
this Open Stack stuff.
Although to be fair,
their own stuff,
Facebook Connect
and the Facebook platform,
it's conceptually very similar.
It's still me taking my account
to another site,
bringing my friends,
sharing activity back.
And so it certainly is sort
of a similar worldview
that you'd want to consider.
It was just sort of annoying
to have to say,
well, gee, I got to build it
twice,
once for the Open Stack
and once for Facebook.
But then a funny thing happened
over the past year.
Facebook decided gee,
it's time to open up our stream
which many thought was the most
closely guarded
piece of data on Facebook.
But they said, no, we're gonna
open it up to developers,
and what's more, we're gonna
do it in an open standard way
with activity streams.
And then they joined
the OpenID foundation
And then they decided,
well, gee, we're not just gonna
join the OpenID foundation.
We're gonna roll out
OpenID ourselves.
And then not a month later,
the big one--boom.
Facebook actually supports
OpenID as a relying party
and does the OpenID and OAuth
and portable contacts
all rolled into one.
And so they are very much
in the game now,
and that's really exciting
because obviously
Facebook is a huge site
and very innovative
and they've got a lot of users
and a lot of data.
And so you as a site
obviously are gonna want people
who are on Facebook
to come and use it.
Now it's certainly the case
that Facebook's
not everything on the web,
right?
In fact if you look at stats
of these sites
that allow you to log in
from lots of different places,
what's very interesting is,
"A", the pie chart has
a lot of big wedges,
so you know,
there's a lot of Facebook
users share
but there's also a lot
of MySpace users,
a lot of Google users,
a lot of Yahoo users,
what have you.
And the other thing
that's interesting
is that the relative sizes
of the wedges
change a lot based on the type
of site that you're going to.
So I believe on snoopdogg.com,
which accepts OpenID log-ins--
think about that for a second--
using JanRain's RPX...
then the MySpace
is more predominant.
But on user voice,
Google's more predominant.
And on other sites,
Yahoo's more predominant.
And especially internationally
it's very different.
And so when you think
about that,
you as a developer,
especially you as
an individual site owner,
you really have
no loyalty per se
to one side or the other.
You just want your users
to be able to come in
and use whatever data
they already have.
You don't want to be in
the business of having to say,
"You can play here
but you can't."
And so what you really want
is to be able
to just write it once
and have it work
across all these websites.
And so it's very exciting
to see
more and more companies
converge around this.
And there's a whole ecosystem
building around this.
So what I showed you--all
those feeds coming in, right?
Well, Plaxo, we were one
of the first to do this.
We had to build it all
ourselves,
so we had custom agents
and pullers and crawlers.
But now there are these great
startups out there
like Gnip,
if you haven't heard of them.
They go out and they figure out
how to get feeds
from all these different
websites.
And then they just push it
to you in real time
and they do
all the scalability stuff.
So we use them for
a bunch of our feeds
where we say, like, anytime
somebody publishes on Delicious,
we know however many
Delicious users
are also connected into Plaxo.
And they just ping us
with oh, hey,
J. Smarr
just saved another bookmark.
And so it shows up, like,
within a minute in our site
and doesn't require us
to have load.
So another benefit
of these standards
is that it allows for, kind of
like Google FriendConnect,
it allows for people
to come in and add value
into the ecosystem even though
they aren't themselves,
you know, end destination.
So very exciting to see
how this is all very frothy.
So just to wrap up and then
we'll have some time
for questions.
As I said at the beginning,
I hope I've shown you
that the web is going social
and the social web
is going open.
And in fact,
I think I can now say it
even more strongly than that.
I think that the web
is actually now social
and the social web
is now open.
And that means
that it is now time
for you guys
to actually get involved
since the only thing
waiting now
is a bunch more developers
who get it
who want to push the envelope
and make great sites
that are easy to use.
So in conclusion, it's time
to start opening your sites up
to users that already
have accounts.
You're not the first website
that they're ever used
and you should start
to take advantage of that.
Give them a socially-tailored
experience.
Don't make them start over
from scratch
with their friends list.
And then think about how
you can let your users
syndicate activity back out
into their stream
and let you ride
that virtuous cycle
'cause it's gonna be
a great ride.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]
And one last comment.
If you want to stay up
more to date
with what's going on,
I know this is a very
fast-moving field.
One thing we've tried
to do to help is a few of us,
Dave Recordon and Chris Messina
and John McCrae and I,
we do a sort of weekly
video podcast
called TheSocialWeb.tv.
Just sort of quick kind of
10 to 20 minute chunks
of the latest news
and trying to understand
what's going on and help
make sense of it in a way
that's not too technical
but helps bring things out.
And we often have guests
from the people
that are building things,
so in addition
to following me on Twitter
or looking at my blog,
this I think you'll find
a probably useful resource.
So I encourage you
to check that out. Yeah.
man: Thank you for
the good presentation.
I appreciate
the excellent input.
Quick question.
In terms of management,
is there a tool that provides
an integrated view
over all those sites
so that I don't have
to go into each container
and manage it separately?
Smarr: So the question is,
"Yeah, how do you manage?"
Well, certainly in part
that's what services
like Plaxo are trying to do.
They're trying to give you
a single place to go
to see what the friends
you care about
are sharing
all across the web.
So if I have Flickr friends,
I can see their photos.
If I have Picasa people,
I think there's
a lot more work to be done
above and beyond that
in terms of managing
permissions
and sharing and notifications
and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
And I think that's gonna
be another fruitful area
of innovation.
So--and I think
as more people--
When I think of questions
like this
I always think of the famous
William Gibson quote.
"The future is already here.
It's just not
evenly distributed yet."
So there are people like me
who already have
that pain in spades.
There's still a lot
of other people
who really aren't using
that many of these tools yet.
But I think as more
and more people
find it easier to get into more
and more of these sites,
tools that help you
manage all that
are going to become more
and more important.
I think it's going to be a great
opportunity for innovation.
Yeah.
man: I saw on Plaxo
that you guys still have
the either Facebook,
Gmail, Google,
and even having your own
sign-up registration system.
Would you advise websites
to actually just do
Facebook and Google
and not have their own
registration system anymore?
Smarr: Yeah,
so good question.
Is it time to get rid
of my own registration system?
Well, so a lot of sites that
already have native users,
like, we have a bunch of users
that already signed up
for Plaxo before this stuff
came out.
We have to have some way
for them to log in
with their
existing credentials.
For new sites,
I think there are sites--
like, so there are sites that
have already gone that route.
There's a cool site for
discussing technical material
called Stack Overflow
and they're 100% OpenID.
And there was a cool
social bookmarking site
called Magnolia
that went 100% OpenID.
And I think Plaxo,
we'd like to get
to be a 100% relying party
as well.
So that basically there'd
be no new Plaxo registrations.
There'd already
be existing sites.
I think, depending on exactly
what your audience is,
you have to ask yourself,
you know--
It's pretty true that probably
pretty much everyone
has an OpenID
right now because
all the bigger
portal providers have it,
but if you think, well, gee,
maybe my users are particularly
non-technical
and not likely to have those,
you might decide
to build your own one.
But I think it's definitely
getting close
to the point where
a lot of people could
just get rid of it altogether
and just say, hey,
go sign up for a Google account
if you don't have one.
And the other advantage there
is there's a lot
of stuff you have to do around
managing account creation.
People try to create spammy
fake accounts and all of that.
And Google and Yahoo
and all those sites
have way more detailed
paranoid teams
figuring out how to track
and trace that stuff.
And so the advantage
of outsourcing authentication
to someone who's gonna do
a better job than you and
they're gonna keep the passwords
more secure and all that.
It's not just not having
to write the code,
but it's you actually get
a more secure experience
at the end so I think
that's another benefit.
Yeah.
man: Well, looking
the other way,
you have many people who have
IDs on multiple sites
that were not OpenID originally.
Is there some way
they can coordinate those
so that their accounts
can be linked retroactively?
Smarr: Yes, there is.
I'm glad you asked that.
So it's a good point, right?
I have lots of URLs
of my profiles around the web.
They're not all OpenIDs,
and even if they were,
it would be kind of annoying
to have
to connect each one
individually.
And so there's a way you can do
this much more easily.
One of the things that
people figured out a while ago
was that you could embed
semantic information
into the structure of links
on the web themselves,
a thing called microformats.
So you could put in,
if I have my website
with contact info
or things like that,
we do this sort of simple
agreed upon set of CSS classes
that a computer parser
could come in and grab data.
And one of those was
if I'm hyperlinking
from one of my profile pages
to another profile page,
I can put rel="me"
in the <a> tag
and that says this is another
profile page about me.
And then you can follow
those rel="me" links.
And the idea is so if I can--
say I use my Google profile
as an OpenID.
And then it has rel="me"
links to my other profiles.
I probably couldn't have
spoofed that
without being able to control
that Google account.
And because I control
that Google account,
I can prove that with OpenID,
you can kind of trust
by transitivity
that those other sites
are mine as well.
And then you can follow those
links downstream and so forth
and you can actually
kind of build
a whole set
of identifiers about me.
And we use this in Plaxo.
I didn't put this in this demo
but maybe I should've.
Google, again, has come
and made this even easier.
The have this thing
called the Social Graph API
where they basically said,
gee, crawling the web
is kind of hard,
but we've already done that
and we've got it sitting
over here on a hard drive
as I understand it.
So why don't we just serve
up all those me links
in a simple API?
So if you look for the Google
Social Graph API,
you can literally put in
any URL and say
give me all the downstream
rel="me" links.
And they'll give you all back
in one shot.
And so we do this when
every time somebody
either signs up
with an OpenID,
or say they hook up
their Twitter feed.
You know, Twitter--
a lot of these sites
put these rel="me" links
in there for you
so you don't have to be
a hacker to do it yourself.
LinkedIn, a bunch
of these sites do that.
We then follow
all those links,
and those are all ways
we know the user.
And if they're mapped
to services we know,
like, we know what
a Flickr URL looks like.
We know what a Twitter URL
looks like.
We can use it to say, hey,
looks like you're
a Flickr user too.
Why don't you hook up
that feed?
And so you get even more
downstream benefit
and richer profiles, so--
and that's a really nice way
of sort of using the
link structure of the web
to get even richer data
beyond just
the initial OpenID handshake.
Yeah.
man: Hi, thanks for your talk.
Smarr: Sure.
man: I just had a question
on what you feel browsers
could do to help enable
all of this.
As I see OpenID integration
has been a little difficult
because of the whole UI
being a pain to deal with.
Smarr: Right.
man: So what can browsers do
to fix this?
Are you aware of
any browser projects,
Firefox, Opera, whoever--
Smarr: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So browsers can be
a huge help in this.
It's a bit of a chicken
and egg thing
because on the one hand, if you
think about it, the browser
is in this wonderful,
privileged position
where it actually knows
all the different websites
that you go to, right?
It's a real pain to say
tell me which of these
50 websites you use
so that I can provide you
with a tailored experience,
whereas the browser actually
knows that.
And the browser also
presumably
has privileged information
to your credentials
on these websites because
it's watched you link--
sign in to all those.
And the browser could present--
you know, secure Chrome
that can't be phished
and you can't redirect
to a fake site and all
that kind of stuff, right?
And there have been people
that have done this.
VeriSign Labs made this plug-in
called OpenID Seatbelt.
And there's a thing called IDIB,
Internet Identity
In the Browser,
that was a project that did
that.
I think Mozilla also--
they showed a video
of some sort of OpenID
in the browser type stuff.
There's a lot
of potential there.
The downside, of course,
is that getting
a browser with this upgraded
functionality
on everybody's desktop
is a real deployment challenge.
And so I don't think we can wait
for browsers to save us.
I think there's gonna have
to be a web native solution.
But I think making it easier
for browsers
to come in and add
additional value on top of that
and simplify the UI
and be more personalized
is an absolute win.
And I would love to see things
like maybe Google Chrome
could do that, right?
That's something that's going
to be distributed
to lots of people that could add
that kind of functionality.
So definitely great
opportunities there
and has been some early work.
But it's mainly that deployment
challenge is tricky.
Yeah.
man: You mentioned earlier
for Facebook friends
you had a background process
that kept the graph
up to sync and everything.
I was wondering if you do that
for any other graph,
like MySpace or whatever,
and if you've run
into scalability problems
with that.
Smarr: Yeah, so scalability
of refriending.
So our core business
traditionally
is actually real sync.
So we have an Outlook plug-in
and a Mac plug-in
and a Thunderbird plug-in
and on and on.
And that does real,
continuous background
full contact and calendar
synchronization.
So we sort of already have
pretty good infrastructure
for that.
And the reason
we and almost all sites
just do a one-time import--
which as I mentioned
is sort of silly 'cause you miss
all the downstream stuff--
is because when
you're taking passwords,
it's not only kind
of a liability
to take the password,
it's a real liability
to store the password, right?
Because if that goes wrong
or if you get hacked,
you're compromising
all the other sites.
And so most sites just throw
away the password
and only do a one-time import.
But once you get
a long-live token,
whether it's a Facebook token
or an OAuth token,
you know have
the luxury of doing
that kind of repeated
background import
and pulling in
the information.
So you could actually get
a lot more value
than when you just did
the one-time thing
because you don't have
the security problem.
So we haven't done as much
as we should, to be honest.
Like, we don't do it right now
with when you do
that Google hybrid flow,
we just pull them in once.
We don't look in the background,
but we clearly should.
Like, we're being stupid
not to do that.
And any site should.
And it's not really
a scalability problem
because you can choose
how often you want to do that.
You could do it once a week
or once a day or whatever.
And in fact we haven't done this
so much with these sites,
but in places like in OpenSocial
where you have potentially
a large number
of user accounts
that need to be updated
with a service,
there's ways of sort
of batching that.
So there's the so-called
two-legged OAuth
where a service will talk
to another service
and say, hey, you can trust me
that I'm Plaxo
because I can prove
that I'm Plaxo.
And so for these ten users
in batch,
could you give me updated
information?
And then they'll just hand them
all over at once
rather than doing it
one user at a time.
So there are tricks like that
for scalability
above and beyond.
But it's really not that bad
because it's just
a periodic thing
in the background.
And maybe someday services
like Gnip will help me
get pushes about my friend
notifications as well as feeds.
I mean, really it's kind of
the same problem.
Yeah.
man: A question in regards
to OpenID and OAuth usage
within enterprises as opposed
to outside of enterprises.
And the second part
of the question,
integration of those with
like Sun's old app
or Microsoft ID.
Smarr: Right.
Great question.
So what about inside
the enterprise?
Actually, it's funny.
They had a whole panel on this
at South by Southwest this year.
And enterprises obviously face
a lot of these same challenges
and there's a lot of
opportunities there.
And traditionally they have
been all of these
kind of one-off hacky systems.
So I think there's a lot
of optimism now
that a lot of these technologies
can be applied
inside the enterprise as well.
And if you don't know
about this,
there's this thing called
the Internet Identity Workshop
which is a kind of unconference
where a bunch of people
in this field get together
and work on these problems
and it's a fantastic thing.
We just had one earlier
this month
and there was
a whole big session.
You had guys from Microsoft
who know all the WS federation
and trust stuff,
and you had people from Google
and you had other people
and they're all getting together
and kind of figuring out
what is different about
the enterprise use cases
and how does that work
with this stuff.
A lot of very interesting
progress being made.
There's already
some early examples.
There's a cool example
where sun.com,
they gave all their employees
sun.com OpenIDs
and the only way
you could get one
is to be a Sun employee.
So you could imagine
if Amazon wants
to give them
an employee discount,
you just log in with
your Sun account
and all of a sudden
it verifies it, right?
So there's all kinds
of interesting models like that.
I think it's still a little bit
early there.
And there's a few extra levels
of paranoia
that maybe need
to be layered on top
as extensions
or something depending
on how big the enterprise is
and how much they want to revoke
and change things or whatever.
But it also makes a ton
of sense to build--
I hope somebody would go build
OpenID plug-in
for something like
Active Directory
'cause that's the point is--
companies have
the credentials already
of their employees.
You'd like to be able
to expose that in a way
that doesn't require
all these consumer--
like Yamir, poor Yamir wants
to build this great
kind of like Twitter-like
application for enterprises.
But they have to go do
these one-off,
like, let me poke a hole
in the firewall
and connect your LDAP
and you dump out and send me--
It's horrible
and it's not core to them.
So if you could just say,
well, you could log in
with your OpenID, then it
might make it a lot easier.
man: It just so happens
at PGP we built a system
using--an OpenID system
using a PGP key.
Smarr: Oh, yeah,
exactly, yeah.
man: Because we have
this large database
on the global directory.
And people got keys in their
machines and there's code.
Smarr: Yeah.
man: It works very well.
Smarr: That's fantastic, yeah.
So I really hope that--
man: So my question is--
Smarr: You've earned a question.
man: I understand that Google
wants to provide
the authentication,
but what if I want
to use that
to log in to Google?
You think they're willing
to open up
to using
another OpenID provider?
You think
it's gonna level off?
Smarr: Will the big guys
be relying parties too?
Well, as Google would say,
they actually already are
a relying party
to thousands
of other websites because
of their Google apps
for your domain project.
So if you're a company
that wants to host
Google apps for your domain,
you can use your own
log-in system
and get a hosted version
of Gmail.
Now it's generally not OpenID
on the back end.
It's things like SAML.
But it's conceptually
the same thing.
And obviously I can't speak
for any of the big companies,
but I think that they all have
the same problem.
So I mean, the first--
the best example so far
is Facebook becoming
an OpenID relying party.
And if you watch
the interview that we did
on The Social Web TV
with Luke Shepherd
who was the main engineer
at Facebook who built that,
what he says is
just because we're big
doesn't mean we don't care
about growth.
In fact, quite the opposite.
And so they have all the same
pain with sign-up friction,
and getting contacts,
and getting information,
and having lost passwords.
And so they're actually very
motivated to make that work.
I think the things
that are most holding it up
are actually more downstream.
So for example, if you want
to go download a desktop client
or use it on your BlackBerry
or your mobile phone,
what do you do then?
And there's good answers
that are being worked out.
But it's not quite
to the point now
where they feel like
for their user base
and their existing deployed apps
and all that,
they can just switch over.
But I do believe
it's coming because
it really will
just drive business value
and you'd be stupid not
to do it.
It's just a matter
of who's going to move first.
man: So what do you think
it's going to take
to leverage, like, the banks,
the credit cards,
the bill paying sites
to start doing this?
Smarr: How do you go
to higher value transactions?
Well, that is something that
a lot of these people
think about.
And again, this--a lot of this
is making the site
more user-friendly,
and at the same time,
it's actually making it
more secure because you're
not giving away your password
and there's a lot more kind of
cryptography under the hood
baked into these OpenID
and OAuth.
And so to me, it's sort of
this rare scenario where
we're actually making the stuff
more user-friendly
and more secure
at the same time.
And I think the higher value
transaction,
people like banks and stuff,
they'll probably take a bit
of a wait-and-see attitude
and see how this plays out
in the lower value space
and then kind of scale it up.
But there's already work being
done with extensions
about being able to prove
that you used
a higher level, kind of
two factor authentication
or things like that
that--so I think we'll see it.
I mean, again, nobody wants
this friction, right?
If I go check out
on an ecommerce site,
I don't want to have
to put in my credit card
over and over and over again
if I can pull it in securely.
So I think I'll see that.
And with three seconds left,
thank you very much
and go be open and connected.
[applause]